kontrolle in der innenstadt seit freitag
gilt in mannheim ausgangssperre zwischen
21 uhr und 5 uhr morgens dürfen die
menschen hier ohne triftige sun liegen
nicht mehr auf die straße
der grund wie bereits in vielen
deutschen städten liegt in mannheim der
inzidenz wert von neuinfektionen pro
100.000 einwohnern deutlich über 200
mannheim ist die erste stadt in baden
württemberg mit dieser maßnahme und
kommt mit der entscheidung der
landesregierung zuvor oberbürgermeister
peter kurz verhängt die ausgangssperre
zunächst bis zum 14 und dezember
die polizei führt massive kontrollen
durch geht dabei aber laut
polizeipräsident mit augenmaß und
fingerspitzengefühl vor
wer sich nicht daran hält muss aber mit
einem bußgeld von bis zu 100 euro
rechnen
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren